every day over two million lines of
JavaScript code are written throughout
the world well maybe to be honest I just
made that up but it sounded plausible
right it sounded like it could be true
and I guess my point is we can agree
that we write a lot of JavaScript code I
don't know if it's two million lines or
20 millions but it's a lot and we write
all that JavaScript code we write blog
posts about JavaScript we hold events
like this one about JavaScript but we
never really take the time to slow down
and ask JavaScript how it's doing you
know make sure things are all right so
today that's exactly what I want to do
as I'm here to talk about the state of
JavaScript in 2018 so okay the state of
JavaScript is actually the name of a
survey that I run and today you're gonna
hear about the the data from the latest
edition this is like an exclusive for
Jes hasn't been published anywhere yet
but just quickly by show of hands who
here has heard about the survey before
just raise your hand wow so quite a few
people and keep your hand up if you
actually filled out the survey this year
yeah nice so first of all thanks thanks
a lot
because I wouldn't be here without all
of you and for those who aren't as
familiar with the project let me give
you a little bit of background so it's
first started two years ago to 2016 and
the first study we did the survey we
will already had over 9,000 responses so
it only made sense to do it again and in
the following year we got 20,000
responses which was really really
amazing but then this year things took a
dark turn well at least in terms of the
design because for the survey it was
great still over 20,000 responses and
when I talk about this project people
often ask me why I'm doing it why go
through the trouble of holding a survey
and for most of my other projects I
don't have a great answer you know why
not but for this project I actually do
have a reason and lll goes back to
JavaScript in 2016 now I don't know if
you guys remember but things were pretty
confusing back then and some might say
they still are but I do think it was
worse in 2016 we had this meme of
JavaScript fatigue anybody remember that
and it seemed like for every piece of
your stack you had like 10 different
options to choose from so that's why I
launched a survey first as a way for
myself to figure out what to learn what
to invest my time in and then you know
if it was helpful for me I thought maybe
it might help others as well so before I
actually show you the data I just want
to talk a little bit about the team
behind the survey in 2016 it was just me
but then I was joined by two other are
really awesome developers to help me can
I just make things bigger and better so
all three of us live in Japan all three
of us obviously are JavaScript
developers and also all three of us are
French so besides meteor
Raphael Bennett who is the author of
react data visualization library called
nigo which is really awesome it has all
the charts you would want including some
that I had never even heard of I'd
exports to canvas SVG it's really great
and obviously it was a huge help to have
him join the team we also have a me
Colombo who is the creator of best fjs
org now the survey is great to get that
like a once a year snapshot of the
trends
but what best obvious does is it
compiles live stats based on github
stars and ranks libraries by their
popularity and they're all tagged and
and sorted so it's a really great
resource to find a good javascript
library for your next project so
definitely do check that out so let's
move on to the data here so it's going
to work in the survey we asked a bunch
of questions and people fell into five
different buckets for any given library
so first we have people who have used a
library and will happily use it again
the next segment is people who would
rather not use that library again maybe
they had a bad experience maybe they
moved on to something else who knows
next up people who have heard of a
library so they haven't used it but they
know what it is and they would like to
learn it or maybe they're not interested
and then finally the last bucket is just
people who have simply not heard about
that library in the survey this year we
had 36 different frameworks and
libraries but I've been told that
there's actually other speakers today so
maybe I should keep it short and let let
them speak and for that reason I decided
to narrow things down to these five
libraries
and I think they provide a pretty good
you know look at the overall trends in
the ecosystem
first up typescript so typescript has
really been on a very positive
trajectory over the past two years it's
gone from 20% to 46% in terms of people
who use typescript and would happily use
it again
now of course the survey doesn't
necessarily represent the whole
community of JavaScript developers it's
just about 20,000 people but still being
able to reach almost half of the survey
audience is a really good performance
especially with such a fast rise why do
people like typescript it helps you
write less error-prone code helps you
write elegant code has great tooling but
by a great team those all make sense
another technology that's really doing
great is react as expected so in two
years it's gone from 48% of developers
having used it and liked it to 64% what
I think is really cool and important to
notice on this chart as well is that
pink bar of would not use it again
developers is fairly small compared to
the red bar and that means that nearly
everybody who uses react would happily
use it again what do people like about
react well it's elegant it has a rich
packaged ecosystem and sure there's a
ton of really great components you can
just drop into your apps and it's a
well-established option I think at this
point it's safe to say that react is the
the leader in its category the front-end
frameworks so those are all reasons to
pick it now I don't think you can talk
about react without also mentioning view
view has really been on an amazing
trajectory over those past two years so
in terms of usage it went from eight
percent to twenty eight percent and
twenty eight percent is you know it's
not yeah that reacts level but it's
still really good especially coming from
a fairly low usage what's even more
impressive I think is in terms of
awareness so two years ago twenty
percent of respondents didn't even know
what view was they had never heard of
you
this year it's down to one percent and
that that's pretty amazing if you ask me
people like views easy learning curve
elegant programming style good
documentation and I think those all
point to view being you know easy to
learn a low barrier to entry is
something you can quickly get started
with and given that it makes sense that
it would be so popular one thing you
might have heard about view that it's
really popular in China
it's being used by a few major Chinese
tech companies and that's actually
something we can see in the data as well
so worldwide the average of happy view
users is twenty eight point eight
percent the u.s. a little bit lower
twenty five point six China though fifty
three point three so almost twice as
much as the world average so I thought
that was interesting
another thing we really wanted to
include in a survey is graph QL it's not
a library it's not a framework but it's
still we think a very important part of
the JavaScript ecosystem so in two years
it's gone from five to twenty percent in
terms of satisfied users very good
satisfaction ratio so that that pink bar
is nearly invisible meaning that almost
everybody who uses graph QL is willing
to use it again
and also a huge number of people who
want to learn graph QL so that's really
important because as more people learn
it and are happy using it you can expect
that red bar to just keep growing and
growing and it wouldn't surprise me if
it reaches 50 percent within a 1 or 2
years okay so up to now we've seen a lot
of pretty positive trends but you know
you can't always be positive sometimes
Oh before I move on sorry forgot why do
people like rescue L so of course the
programming style the momentum and the
tooling things like graphical Apolo dev
tools are pretty helpful but yeah like I
was saying there's also some not
negative but less positive trends one of
them is angular sorry to angular users
here don't be mad at me but angular is
actually doing fine in terms of users so
that the red bar is pretty constant even
growing a little bit the problem is
there's lots of people who would rather
not use angular again maybe they've
moved on on to react or view or maybe
they're they're unhappy with angular at
the same time the number of people who
want to learn angular is also decreasing
so what do people not like about angular
some people feel it's a little bit
bloated or complex a little bit clumsy
or hard to learn and those don't really
mean that angular is like a bad product
but I think it does mean that it's gonna
have a hard time competing with react
and views momentum but anyway you know
we'll see how it fares in the upcoming
years so there's been a lot of stats
it's still the morning some of you are
lying down and maybe falling asleep so
let's play a little game so while
looking at the results we we figured out
it was pretty interesting to plot the
satisfaction ratio of a library in other
words how many people would be had
again versus just the usage and I'm
gonna plot points on this chart and your
job is to guess which of the six library
it corresponds to so I'm gonna pick some
victims in the front row to take a guess
and the first one has really high
satisfaction and also really high usage
do you want to take a guess you say
react let's see yeah you got it right
it was react that yeah good job good
this one has really high satisfaction
nearly as high as react but really low
usage so it's kind of a niche thing
maybe a up-and-comer do you want to take
a guess polymer
no not polymer you wanna not view okay
one more person I heard react yeah nice
job
[Applause]
so this one has high usage but the
satisfaction not quite there
let's pick someone new angular you said
it not me yeah
angular next up this one has low usage
and also low satisfaction who is brave
enough to take a guess
polymer let's see let's see if it's
polymer no it's amber and then this one
yeah this one is easy just shout it out
view yeah it's beautiful
yeah so you'll notice the chart is
divided in quadrants and I think that
can actually help us identify the trends
in any given category so the first
quadrant is what I call the assess
quadrant and those are the libraries
with high usage sorry high satisfaction
and low usage so these are other things
you kind of want to keep an eye on maybe
try out because they they have a lot of
potential but they're not really
mainstream yet next up you have the
adopt quadrant those are the safe that's
you know high usage people like them you
can safely adopt them for your project
and then you have analyzed so these are
other things that are pretty widespread
lots of usage in fact you might be using
them yourself
yet a lot of people aren't quite
thrilled with them and are maybe
reanalyzing whether they still match
their needs and finally the avoid
quadrant so those are the things yeah a
load test of action low usage again
doesn't mean they're bad tools but if
you're starting out on a new project or
maybe starting out as a developer
yourself you might wanna you know avoid
them now I can already tell I'm gonna
get a lot of tweets about this slide but
you know I'll take the risk
so if you want to find all this data and
much much much more you can go to state
of J's comm in about a week or ten days
we're still putting the finishing
touches to the results site but this
year I think is going to be really cool
there's a we collected more data we have
more visualizations so definitely go
check it out I want to end on the
positive note
so we also asked some more like opinion
questions about JavaScript what's that
yeah I kinda added that last minute as
you can tell so is JavaScript moving in
the right direction
do you strongly agree strongly disagree
and the proportion of people who
strongly agree is actually going up up
to 51% and I think that's a great sign
and it makes sense good we wouldn't have
be having events like this one with
thousands of people if you guys didn't
like JavaScript so in conclusion well
all these stats are you know at the end
of the day they're just tools I'm not
saying they reach should replace using
your own best judgment because the most
popular library might just not fit your
needs and on the other hand more niche
lesser known framework might be exactly
what you need so definitely use that as
one factor into picking libraries making
technological choices but you know if
you use ember or angular please don't be
mad at me so thanks so much for
listening and hopefully see you all
again in 2019
[Applause]